earlier this morning we spoke to FEMA
deputy administrator Daniel canoe ski
who says the decrease in Florence's top
winds does not make this storm any less
of a threat the impacts were really
worried about water that flooding once
it gets inland and that 13 feet of storm
surge are unchanged so forget about the
the category number what we have to be
concerned about are the real deadly
impacts we also asked about a story we
first told you about yesterday about
FEMA's response to Hurricane Maria CBS
News obtained photos showing millions of
bottles of water that have been sitting
on an airport runway in sabor Puerto
Rico since last fall when the hurricane
hit those are excess water bottles those
were not needed during the response
phase and we're not distributed by the
governor for Rico or FEMA for that
reason well the optics sure looked bad
but you're telling us you're comfortable
with how FEMA handled that situation I
am and we'll be putting out a statement
later today with an exact timeline for
this situation I'm confident that those
that needed those bottles of water got
them during the response phase and these
were excess bottles of water that were
again transferred to save money for the
American taxpayer in January according
to a new Washington Post Kaiser Family
Foundation survey 50 percent of Puerto
Ricans say people in their households
could not get enough water to drink in
the year since Maria